plus besoin de plans pour savoir où
porter le masque en centre ville
des panneaux ont été installés à
l'entrée des rues concernées
depuis samedi dernier le message a eu le
temps de passer et une nouvelle habitude
s'est installée c'est une contrainte
mais je préfère ça donc non je
continuerai à venir l'envié de tout
autant qu'avant ah bah ça va pas nous
empêcher de venir au centre ville bien
sûr je le portais en fête en ville déjà
depuis depuis la fin du confinement donc
non mais au contraire c'est toujours le
masque dans la poche et si je peux
l'enlever de hors jeu relève on peut pas
et bien si on peux pas je le mets bien
sûr tu disciplinés et une chance pour
cette dame et les autres étourdi pas de
verbalisation pour le moment au centre
ville et pour les commerçants
apparemment pas vraiment de changement
ya beaucoup moins de monde l'après-midi
soit hétéro chaleur forcément ça ça
contre un petit peu mais sinon dans
l'ensemble dans ça va ça va donc on a
toujours autant de monde surtout le
matin les jours de marché la plupart des
personnes n'ont absolument pas modifié
on a même constaté une recrudescence de
on va dire de la fréquentation étant
donné que les personnes sont revenus de
vacances
maintenant mon ya toujours quelques
irréductibles ou qui se croient
irréductibles en ne portant pas le
masque
pour le directeur de la fédération des
commerçants du centre-ville ce port du
masque impose y est une bonne chose même
si la mesure peut dissuader certains
clients quand même on sait que les
personnes qui viennent un centre-ville
qui ont fait la démarche du port du
masque qui veulent se mettre du gel sur
les mains qui appliquent les gestes
barrière eux sont des vrais
consommateurs on a un grand magasin à
dijon qui annonce ouvertement une baisse
de fréquentation dans son magasin mais
une hausse du panier moyen en hausse de
chiffre d'affaires pendant l'été et pour
inciter à venir acheter masquer la
fédération des commerçants offrent même
un masque réutilisables des 30 euros
d'achat
[Musique]